mélanie et jean martin il se questionne
devrait-il attendre ou s'acheter un
véhicule électrique maintenant
aujourd'hui il vient de voir le modèle x
et 40 chez volvo à ville mont-royal
propriétaire d'une résidence en gaspésie
le couple s'inquiète de l'autonomie de
la batterie en hiver
2,3 s'aggravant dépend du kilométrage
exacte de ce que vous allez faire comme
accélération aussi de la vitesse que
vous allez rouler il ya beaucoup de
vecteurs que vont elles changer le tout
mais moi je calcule ray ne vende route
moi je calcule rêve vraiment le tir au
moins 1h30 2h de plus de longs trajets
possibles grâce à un réseau de bornes de
recharge plus étoffé il y en a plus de
7000 à travers le québec dont 800 bornes
rapides ce qui élimine l'angoissé de la
panne reste la question de l'usure de la
batterie qui préoccupe aussi mélanie et
jean martin on peut s'attendre à quad en
france dans quatre heures par exemple on
sait pas vraiment à quoi s'attendre ce
que je peux vous dire si je peux prendre
l'exemple des hybrides branchables qu'on
a on a encore un très bonne autonomie
après quatre ans ici la composition des
batteries soulève des questions bien des
experts le disent leurs technologies
s'est beaucoup améliorée ces dernières
années et ça continue et autres
avantages selon simon pierre rioux les
batteries peuvent avoir plusieurs vies
alors qu'avec la batterie lors ce qui
est en fin de vie passe d'un gros
réservoir énergétique on voit capable de
recycler de façon pratiquement est
défini avec 1 5 % de perte d'une fois à
l'autre pour pouvoir créer une nouvelle
batterie si la voiture électrique reste
plus écologique que la voiture à essence
certains considèrent quand même que ce
n'est pas l'option la plus écologique
c'est l'objet même qui est le problème
selon olivier ducharme si on veut
vraiment protéger l'environnement il
faut surtout moins d'autos sur nos
routes alors que la tendance actuelle
est à la hausse 2 % de plus l'année
dernière au québec encore continué à
vouloir avoir le plus en plus de voix se
rallie gaspiller de plus en plus de
ressources naturelles pour le couple une
voiture électrique reste tout de même
pas dans la bonne direction si le prix
d'achat élevé reste un obstacle les
incitatifs gouvernementaux
li 1000 $ de québec et 5000 $ du fédéral
compense en partie sans compter les
économies d'essence et d'entretien
estimé à 2000 $ au bout de quatre ans on
a pris la décision
de se procurer un véhicule électrique
c'est là que tout le monde est rendue je
pense je me sens de monte ils ne sont
pas seuls il se vend en moyenne au
québec 135 véhicules électriques chaque
jour
pour les verts il faut toutefois s'armer
de patience le temps d'attentes selon
fabricant varient de deux semaines à
plus d'un an ici et les insérer radio
canada montréal